honestly I love my friends and if they
wanted to marry my husband I would
definitely encourage it
I've done the seven day free trial of
the Quran the app and it exceeded All my
expectations alhamdulillah I was worried
that was an overrated product that's
what he fought until he tried it what
was the system you can build a habit
with the Quran by seven day free trial
promises no credit card details required
at all and you just you didn't yourself
is it overrated or is it underrated
brothers and sisters and zeeshan The
Honorable Gentleman on my left here he's
on my left so is the shaytan so brothers
and sisters today well not today I saw a
video and on this video there was an
ahabi system who was advising the sister
now this sister it seems like recently
on Tick Tock and social media she's
becoming very popular and lots of
brothers are sharing the stuff she says
because she sounds good to the ear how
because she says stuff like you know if
my husband tells me to jump I'll jump
how high my husband wants to go on the
stage I'll do whatever my husband wants
and I'll be honest with the other man
it's like wow they're a woman like that
exists the point is the following she
says something about polygamy now to me
it was like okay
it sounds good to the ER but is it
I don't want to say genuine because I
don't doubt anybody's intentions however
let's watch it for ourselves and hear if
what she's saying is applicable is it
reality or is it some kind of a dream
that she's selling to sisters and
brothers statistically there are more
women on earth
and one woman there would be millions of
women that are single like why would you
want that for your sisters that you love
honestly I love my friends and if they
wanted to marry my husband I would
definitely encourage it office sounds
amazing to the ear isn't everyone making
Dua my wife comes home and says that to
me
yes and no now one thing that we need to
understand and one of the reasons we
started the bitter truth Show brothers
and sisters is to tackle these issues
when it comes to gender roles
understanding the man's mind
understanding the woman's mind so we can
get to know each other better and it can
help us understand each other better now
what this is saying yes there are more
women than men there's a Hadith for the
prophet Muhammad he said a time would
come if I'm not mistaken maybe 50 men
every there'll be so much woman that a
man will be a guardian over 50 woman
something along those lines yeah so the
point is what yes and that's one of the
reasons why polygamy is a solution one
of the reasons why as you guys know I've
been very vocal about the polygamy issue
and that I believe every single man is
polygamous by Nature I've been saying
this day in day out however so sisters
before you like tune out one second what
this sister is saying goes against her
nature unless she is some an exception
to the rule which we know they exist but
she's like an exception exception
exception to the rule like a very very
special sister that she is saying that
she has no problem
her husband marrying her friend I mean
let alone okay another woman her friend
to me is like um really is this a
reality sister and is this correct you
bringing it out there why now the pr the
the reason is this men for example we
are created in a certain way where we do
not like a certain thing for example
that we judge a Woman by her past and a
woman judges a man by his future so I
make this very clear that for example if
a man was to go to his potential wife is
going to marry and says I wanna I am
planning on getting a second wife most
likely she would judge him by that and
say you know what I don't know if I will
marry you or I'm gonna put in the
marriage contract that's within the
nature does it mean it's right or wrong
no am I asking for anyone to go and
divorce or not marry someone because of
this I'll say no every man is believing
this by Nature however
for a woman we understand and
acknowledge that that's the way she's
created now for a man most cases sisters
come and ask his questions he's asking
me about my past men judge a Woman by
their past if she has had some kind of a
past personally I a lot of men would say
no so you guys are wide in that way when
it comes to a man's future with multiple
women and with a man is more you a woman
and her past with different men that
bothers us this bothers you now this
system to come and say that it's fine
you know my friends if they want to
marry no it's not sister no it's not you
know very well it's not to put this out
there as if this is the norm is wrong
because what you're doing is you're
giving me a perception that this is the
norm and that is how it should be no the
best of the best of women
one day she was bringing food to the
prophet peace be upon him the prophet
peace be upon Him didn't know he had
wife brought um he had food
brought from one of his others why
otherwise and when he came and imagine
he's sitting with the sahaba brothers
imagine you see him with your boys yeah
your wife is bringing the food and then
she smashes on the floor smash out of
jealousy yeah and the scholars say is
she blameworthy of this not necessarily
her nature as women they are jealous is
totally different to the way they're
jealous as a man but the point is what
she got jealous it's as simple as that
yes so now the point is what the point
is the following are we now trying to
say that we are better than this woman
no no the point is what no matter who
you are are you a woman you are bound to
be jealous you are bound to want your
man for yourself and you are bound to be
upset that if he gets a second wife let
alone being marrying your friend don't
come and tell me sister that you're
gonna be okay with it and like please
don't do that because you're given a
false perception to men and also you're
making woman feel as if they are now
abnormal to feel jealous no they're not
them being jealous getting upset having
a tantrum being angry vocalizing it and
to some who go to the length of divorce
which I would say is kind of Crossing
Lines in the context where there's a
discussion on it is it oh of course I
was going to come and say Haram some
Scholars will say it's not a valid
reason it's a different topic but the
point is it is natural for women to be
upset about it and I advise any sister
to not end their marriage because he
gets a second wife if he's a good man
he's practicing he fears Allah he gives
you your rights his protection is
provides do not do that mistake by
divorcing him because he wants to get
married again because like I said before
this is in a man's biology it's in its
nature so in a nutshell just want to
wrap up to it ain't a Seer to the sister
there is a lot of controversial things
that you're saying I don't doubt your
intentions I'm not saying this or that
whatever your husband you said that he's
her second wife two wives or three wives
I don't know what it might be and you're
open to applicants or whatever maybe may
Allah bless you preserve you increase
your husband's uh wives no problem yeah
but to make it seem as if it's abnormal
for a woman to be jealous or this that
no this is wrong and we will call it out
when it's wrong even though it's for our
favor like Allah says in the Quran speak
the truth even if it's against yourself
so what you're seeing in my favor I
would love to support you all day all
night and say you know what yes sister
you're right I can't do that because the
truth is more beloved to me than me
talking or approving what you're saying
just because it's good to my ears all
the brothers ears no I believe this
specific video is wrong and to portray
that this is
how it should be yes you can't expect it
but most of the time women are wide in a
certain way there's going to be jealousy
and that is no more her being upset is
normal crying maybe sometimes shouting
as long as there's no Haram stuff not
being said it's a normal behavior and
but the best of the woman who walked
this Earth our mothers the Believers uh
the Believers mothers here the prophet
peace be upon him his wives had these
issues let alone yourself so please
let's be careful to what we convey on
social media because we give wrong
messages same with social media couples
who are portraying this lovely amazing
marriage everything's so perfect and
then you have individuals who are like
oh my gosh why is my marriage not like
that because it's fake it's like
Superman jumping from 10th building and
you're like oh let me try that let me
put a cape on oh I died it's my
generator come to my generator yeah
we'll come to janaza we don't know if we
make Dua for you you know because it's
like suicide brother so do not look at
social media influences and let's be
responsible who are public figures
responsible with our content because
these things cause issues in the
household
and for more videos like bitter truth
Etc where we discuss these topics
in-laws getting involved past present
how men think gender roles God was a bit
of true show
till next time
if there is more videos where I don't
see the sisters videos but if there's
more videos that the sisters may be
saying things we can just maybe correct
argue with somebody inshallah and may
Allah bless her and her family and keep
them firm with all the co-wives
assalamualaikum